you walk us through that really cool map
and show us where the danger spots are
well yeah I've walk you through Texas
North Dakota a few places with higher
actually Texas I think is not
contracting but it's really the places
where you have higher energy sector
exposure where North Dakota and Wyoming
basically right yeah basically so we
don't have broad economic weakness the
United States at all we have mining
sector railroad sector energy sector
weakness we have modest weakness in
manufacturing but even manufacturing is
not contracting so I know a lot of
people have been sick comparing this to
1980 oil crash where we saw similar
regional weakness in the economy but
overall the economy didn't go into a
recession does that look like a proper
parallel to you it does yeah that was in
1986 when oil prices fell very sharply
it actually we had regional recessions
that kind of rolled through the economy
for a few years and you did have some
losses in the banking system related to
that so it was a real event
it just wasn't sufficient to cause the
whole economy to start to to fall and
that's kind of what we're looking at
right there so at the far left hand
corner that little dip that's what it
what happened in the last hour crap
that's right and those states that fell
were precisely the ones that were the
energy centric states Oklahoma Texas etc
what would you want to see for you to
change your mind is there data that
would say okay this is actually spilling
over and greater than I thought it was
well I mean the labor market is is a
coincident or slightly lagging indicator
but but really to get into recession you
need all sectors to get a little bit
more risk-averse and people pull back on
investment and and hiring plans across
the board really not what we're seeing
and you know the labor report was just
out on Friday and it actually looks
pretty good with with some very strong
income numbers for for households don't
you bank continues to have the thesis
that the weak productivity we've seen is
actually due to weak demand and if we
don't see demand really pick up the
companies that have been hiring are
going to have to fire because they're
just not going to be able to or need to
make the products what do you think
about that well it's hard to really call
it weak demand when consumptions been
running in the high twos recently so
we've got very strong can some
growth business investment is is kind of
a mixed picture but construction is is
growing strongly I think there are some
longer-term drags on productivity that
matter a little more so I wouldn't have
exactly that that view but I I think the
issue right now is is with risk aversion
on the rise and with concentrated stress
happening in energy is this gonna create
real losses clog up our credit system
and spook people to the point that they
cut back on hiring an investment where
they otherwise should not there's one
common argument or one school of thought
which is that historically recessions
are caused by the Fed so ultimate leave
the Fed Titans to the point that slows
the economy where are we you know what
at what point how much further can
defend tighten without that happening
again well I mean the market has voted
and decided that the Fed won't be
tightening for for some time I don't
really agree with the market at this
point but I don't know maybe I would you
say you don't agree do you mean you
think the Fed will hike more times or
that the Fed can I think the Fed will
hike in 2016
so many times so you're thinking up to
three times okay and and so and that's
basically a second half recovery I mean
remember the unemployment rate just fell
below 5% core inflation is drifting
higher and wages are beginning to
accelerate so you know it's early
February we're in a risk appetite panic
and you know it's important not to just
extrapolate this through the year but
actually I think you know the recession
risks may be rising nicely for 2017
because by then we could have a much
lower unemployment rate we could have
faster wage growth and you could get to
the point where the Fed is actually you
know needs to hike even if global growth
stays fragile and if credit growth stays
fragile credit is a long-lived lead
indicator for for what happens so just
because credit is seizing up now doesn't
mean instantly go in recession it could
be a year from now and no.8 you know it
was a lot earlier the stress in credit
markets that preceded the actual severe
economic stress by by many months